alors qu'elle ait fait tout cela aura
avec nous faisant de benoît qui est pdg
d'aéro montréal qui la grappe
aérospatiale de montréal du grand
montréal et même du québec du québec
bonsoir dans benoît bonsoir quel est
votre degré d'inquiétude ce soir par
rapport à l'avenir de bombardier en fait
on a tous entendu les nouvelles depuis
deux jours bombardier c'est un fleuron
ici au québec bombardier à des
difficultés financières des dates
importantes bombardier devra faire des
choix
alors moi je ne peux pas vraiment me
prononcer pour bombarder c'est la haute
direction qui va décider des choix
qu'ils vont faire cependant ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'au québec on a
une grappe aérospatiale qui est très
dynamique qui est fortement structurée
et c'est grâce à bombardier au cours des
15-20 dernières années qu'on a réussi à
bâtir une industrie aussi forte
une chaîne de valeur une chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui est de classe
mondiale en fait et on dit que montréal
est la troisième capitale mondiale de
l'aérospatiale et c'est grâce à
bombardier sont est capable de prétendre
que montréal est la troisième capitale
mondiale on à boeing à seattle on à
airbus à toulouse mais là avec les
difficultés que vivent bombardier mais
on va on va se rabattre je dirais sur
d'autres entreprises qui sont très
performantes aussi au sein de la grappe
jusqu'à quel point la chaîne
d'approvisionnement le monde
aérospatiale tourne autour et dépend en
fait de bons d'artillerie en fait je
vous dirais que si vous m'aviez posé
cette question il ya douze ans je vous
aurais dit forte dépendance au tour de
bombardier surtout la base en 1985 pme
ici au québec qui plusieurs dépend des
deux bombardiers c'est l'unique client
mais depuis
une douzaine d'années dix ans maintenant
avec aéro montréal les programmes la
mobilisation on a beaucoup de travailler
avec les pme pour qu elles diversifient
leurs marques c est qu elle puisse aller
chercher d'autres clients
s'internationaliser donc si vous me
posez la question aujourd'hui je pense
que en plus on a développé au cours des
12 dernières années un écosystème très
très fort en matière de recherche
développement avec nos consortium de
recherche les universités les centres de
recherche les écoles de formation et
l'industrie alors s'il bombardier sort
de la 220 x et airbus qui dirige déjà
mais qui est totalement engagé dans la
220 et si bombardier vent les avions
d'affaires à textron par exemple que
bombardier n'est plus finalement dans
l'aviation ici est ce que ça change
votre écosystème qu'est ce que ça change
dans votre écosystème mais ça change que
bombardier
ça va nous toucher directement comme
québécois parce que c'est notre fleuron
mais il ya d'autres joueurs qui
appellent parce que ça fragilise votre
écosystème
pas du tout moi je pense que m'inspire
pas du tout c'est sûr que si on a une
compagnie qui a été fondée ici au québec
dont les actifs sont ici au québec c'est
rassurant si on regarde ce qui se passe
dernièrement avec airbus avec mitsubishi
ces gens là ces compagnies-là ont flairé
la bonne affaire
ils ont vu qu'on avait des talents
exceptionnels c'est au québec qu'on a
développée grâce à bombardier tous les
investissements qu'on a fait pour
développer l'avion ces séries qui est
devenu l'airbus 220 tous les
investissements ce sont des ingénieurs
ce sont des étudiants qui ont fait des
stages en entreprise on investissait
plus qu'un milliard par année un arrêt d
ici au québec c'est énorme
alors livre est ce que ça donne mauvaise
presse qui se passe présentement parce
qu'on parle de bombardier puis on suit
ça sur tous les réseaux et les ligues
grandes agences de presse
internationales qu'ils aident à vous
voyez vous ils sont en train de tomber
est ce que ça donne mauvais esprit c'est
tout à fait ça sert les compétiteurs
tout à fait oui alors nous faut faire
attention à ce niveau là ce qu'on dit
sur l'écosystème québécois parce que on
veut quand même
maintenez là
activités du québec pour pouvoir bâtir
et continuer à développer notre secteur
aérospatial airbus est venu ici avec
l'airbus avec l'avion ces séries ils ont
pris en charge cet avion là ils ont
doublé le nombre d'avions cette année on
construise ont livré des avions ils vont
demeurer au québec
et voilà force de l'écosystème ils
veulent investir davantage si mitsubishi
est venu au québec dont call raison
parce que bombardier a laissé partir des
ingénieurs l'année dernière ils ont avec
l'expertisé tact à l'année recherché
qu'attendez-vous du gouvernement du
québec dans fait que je m'attends -
gouvernement du québec peu importe car
et sexy jamais bombardier devait être
pris par un acquéreur potentiel que ce
soit extra ou un autre il faut que ça se
fasse dans des conditions des bonnes
conditions il faut s'assurer que les
emplois soient maintenues il faut
s'assurer que le leadership reste au
québec que la r&d aussi soit pour
poursuivre se développe ici au québec et
que les fournisseurs gardent leur
contrat hier mehran ebrahimi sur nos
ondes spéciale du secteur aérospatial
aéronautique disait le problème c'est
pas alain bellemare ou c'est pas de
savoir si québec doit mettre plus
d'argent au moins d'argent d'hambourg
bardy c'est la stratégie globale des
pouvoirs publics est ce que nos pouvoirs
publics nos gouvernements vont assez
loin pour développer l'aérospatiale
l'aéronautique comme on le fait à sya
tôt à toulouse
au brésil on n'a pas le même contexte un
ici au québec au canada on ne développe
pas d'avions de chasse
on ne développe pas de matériel dans le
domaine de la défense par le domaine
militaire
alors quand aux etats-unis le pentagone
finance beaucoup de recherche et
développement l'innovation la même chose
en france en allemagne et cetera alors
ce qui se passe c'est que développer des
avions faire des programmes d'avions
avec des avions de dernière génération
les plus évolué au monde ça requiert des
sommes très importantes et bombardier a
dû assumer ces sommes là
pour développer la technologie c'est sûr
que ça crée énormément d'emplois ça
génère de l'innovation c'est stimulant
pour les jeunes aussi de faire carrière
dans le secteur là et les pays
développés tout le monde rêve d'avoir
une industrie aérospatiale donc il faut
que les gouvernements soient au rendez
vous le gouvernement du québec l'a très
bien compris
ils ont supporté notre industrie c'est
encore moi je pense je pense qu'ils
devraient le faire encore mais peut-être
une autre forme on voit que le
gouvernement legault et très innovateur
on l'a vu dans l'investissement qu'ils
ont fait dans mitsubishi au niveau du
partage de risque avec eux dont il ya
sûrement des façons d'arriver à
maintenir notre industrie aérospatiale
au québec soit avec bombardier soit avec
des nouveaux entrants mais toujours avec
l'aide du gouvernement et aussi le
fédéral joue de noah merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup